Captain America Iron Man Thor Hulk Black
Widow and Hawkeye these six heroes have
led the charge within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe for more than 10
years and twice as many movies and with
Avengers endgame bringing them all
together again
it seems fitting to go over each of
their story arcs leading up to this epic
crescendo of course trying to watch
every MCU movie in a row is a nearly two
day long endeavor at this point so we've
gone ahead and condensed each original
Avengers story for you here's how each
Avenger got to endgame the MCU got its
start when Ironman arrived in theaters
in 2008 Robert Downey jr. 'he's
impressive performance introduced us to
a narcissistic Tony Stark who is used to
having things his own way until he got
kidnapped by the ten rings and had to
build his first Iron Man suit to regain
his freedom from there he inched his
name into the Marvel Hall of Fame by
helping stop threats such as Iron Monger
whiplash the Chitauri invasion of New
York Aldrich Killian and Ultron but
Starks true arc always focused on his
inner struggle as he came to grips with
who he was without his tricks and toys
once just a billionaire playboy the man
has slowly evolved into a thoughtful
caring hero his loyalty to Pepper Potts
and father figures status to Peter
Parker are excellent examples of how
he's matured over time and then there's
the role he's played in setting the
stage for the Thanos epic his prophetic
vision and age of Ultron gave him a
unique sense of urgency that continued
to fuel him as he tried to prepare for
the Mad Titans impending arrival
danos clearly had an affinity with the
iron avenger too as shown through his
assertion that they were both cursed
with knowledge during an infinity war
leaving a potential showdown between the
two and endgame a positively tantalizing
prospect while the Hulk has been a bit
of an enigma throughout the MCU thus far
his story can basically be broken down
into three eras first we have his solo
film which came out after Iron Man it
showcased Bruce Banner then played by
Edward Norton already on the run in love
with Betty Ross and relentlessly pursuit
by her father the film ended with banner
having more or less come to terms with
the other guy the second era opened when
Mark Ruffalo picked up the mantle and
Avengers banner and the Green Machine
seemed to have taken a few steps back at
that point as neither wanted to
surrender control to the other
the duo continued to help the Avengers
for
while afterward and sparks even began to
fly between banner and BlackWidow and
age of Ultron but it all came to a
screeching halt when Hulk took over at
the end of the movie and flew the Quinn
jet into space the third era began when
Hulk showed up two years later in thor
ragnarok beginning a three movie
character arc this news story continued
his hope remained out of sight
throughout most of infinity war the end
of the three-part story will take place
an end game with some sort of climactic
event likely in store for the Jade giant
Black Widow has proven to be an
absolutely invaluable addition to the
team over the years she first appeared
in Iron Man 2 already trained as an
accomplished spy and assassin working
for shield she showed up again in
Avengers and played a critical role in
ending the Battle of New York when she
closed the portal with Loki's scepter
she went on from there to help topple
hydras infiltration of shield and bring
Ultron down in sokovia she turned heads
yet again when she switched sides to
join team cap in Civil War helping
Captain America and Bucky Barnes escape
in the Quinjet
shiri emerged with cap and company in
the early minutes of infinity war and
made her presence known throughout the
fight in Wakanda
Black Widow has been featured heavily in
the endgame trailers and seems likely to
be right by cap side when the action
picks up again Thor has enraptured fans
since the moment in the only ur was seen
in the end credits scene of Iron Man 2
the son of Odin kicked things off on a
low note in for by being sent into exile
after he disobeyed his father however by
the end of the movie he had grown into a
character that appreciated the
seriousness of his responsibilities as a
Prince of Asgard after his opening film
he provided some serious muscle for the
Avengers in the Battle of New York he
then flew off to stop the Dark Elf
Malekith from wiping out the entire
universe in his second solo adventure
from there he doubled back to earth
where he helped stop Ultron and
conducted some preliminary infinity
stone research however the character
truly hit his stride in Thor Ragnarok
the humor infused capstone to Thor's
trilogy brought a whole new angle to the
Asgardian as he struggled with the loss
of his father took down his sister and
ultimately took up his kingship the
movie also set the stage for infinity
war which opened with many of the
surviving as Guardians being wiped out
by Thanos during infinity war Thor's
character arc reached an electrifying
conclude
as he forged Stormbreaker summoned to
bifrost on his own and even managed to
land what looked like a fatal blow
against Thanos it's no understatement to
say that the king of Asgard enters
endgame ready for a rematch
much like natasha romanoff Clint Barton
has made an MCU living off cameos and
supporting roles and his lack of
superpowers naturally puts him at a
disadvantage but that's never done much
to stop the arrow wielding hero from
making his mark
Hawkeye made his first appearance in
Thor as an agent of shield he showed up
again in Avengers when Loki possessed
him with the mine stone once he was
freed from the Asgardians influence
however he was quick to join the
Avengers in their successful defense of
New York City from there his path led to
age of Ultron where he brought the
refugee Avengers to his family's home
the revelation that Barton was at heart
a family man brought a new dimension to
the character after the mess in sokovia
Barton retired from the Avengers only to
be drawn back into the fray by cap
during civil war the whole affair ended
with him under house arrest during the
scene at the Avengers HQ an infinity war
Black Widow reminded the Avengers and
the audience about his current legal
status
where's Clint after the whole Accord
situation he and Scott took a deal was
too tough on their families on house
arrest while he may have sat out for the
first half of the two-part epic the
trailers for endgame have revealed that
chances are good we'll see quite a bit
more apartment
this time likely under the guise of
Ronan while it may seem hard to believe
Steve Rogers was the last of the big six
to make his entrance into the MCU his
first solo movie coming right before
Avengers traced Rogers path from a
rejected military recruit to the Super
Soldier Captain America after stopping
Red Skull in his origin film Captain
went on to save the world again in
Avengers becoming the heart and soul of
the superhero team next cap teamed up
with Black Widow and Sam Wilson aka
Falcon to take down a Hydra infiltrated
shield in Captain America Winter Soldier
from there he led the Avengers into
their battle against Ultron in the
second Avengers installment in civil war
he chose to defend Bucky Barnes put his
shield through iron man's chest armor
and was forced to go into hiding he
re-emerged from exile and infinity war
after being informed of Thanos imminent
arrival there's no doubt that cap is
more than capable of holding
his own in a fight but much like Tony
Stark his true journey so far has
revolved around his inner struggles over
time he shifted from a shining beacon of
national hope to a fugitive on the run
from the very government that created
him no matter how bad things have gotten
Steve Rogers has never lost his ability
to follow his moral compass a fact that
will certainly play into his decisions
in endgame while the six founding
Avengers have had their own personal
story arcs throughout the first three
phases of the MCU
the story of their alliance as a team of
Earth's Mightiest Heroes has also played
a prominent role in the lead-up to
endgame thanks to Captain Marvel we now
know that Nick Fury was given the idea
to create the protector initiative in
the mid 90s after seeing how real the
threats of an intergalactic invasion
could be of course he fittingly renamed
it the Avengers initiative creating the
famous name for the Super Hero Squad
after he saw that it was Dan versus
callsign in the Air Force the first
Avengers featured director fury as he
assembled the Avengers to face the
threat of Loki and the mind stone sure
the team had a few early issues but you
can't gather that many eccentrically
powerful personalities into a single
group without expecting some kind of
friction besides who doesn't want to
watch Thor take on Hulk and a
Helicarrier but after getting over those
growing pains they mesh together
beautifully as they took on Loki bottled
up the shatori hordes and NYC and sent a
nuke is a parting gift before closing up
the invasion portal as the credits
rolled the team looked good enough to
eat you know like at a table almost an
entire phase after the first Avengers
movie its sequel Avengers age of Ultron
arrived in theaters the Battle of New
York spooked Tony Stark enough to begin
working on what he called the Ultron
program which was meant to protect the
world from future global threats of
course the whole experiment went
horribly wrong when they introduced the
mind stone to the equation inadvertently
creating Ultron in the process
age of Ultron provided an opportunity
for the team to grow while also
introducing classic Silver Age
characters Scarlet Witch and vision both
characters have become Avengers staple
sense and are even getting their own
miniseries Ultron also served as a
launch pad for Thanos and the Infinity
stones to move to
center stage after their high points and
Avengers the next chapter of the group's
history would be shadowed by internal
friction as if Ultron wasn't bad enough
just a couple of movies later the
Avengers turned on each other in Captain
America Civil War with Hulk and Thor
bolt out of the picture the third
installment of caps trilogy saw the rest
of the gang fall out part after an
operation went south
leading to civilian casualties and a
public relations nightmare the event
sparked the demand for the Avengers
designed the sokovia accords which were
designed to provide a measure of
government control over super-powered
vigilantes split over whether to sign
the Accords or not Tony Stark and Steve
Rogers rallied the Avengers into two
separate groups before duking it out
during the famous airport battle in
Leipzig the story ended with Rogers &
Company on the lam but the rest of the
Avengers either technically operating
under government control or under house
arrest needless to say it was a low
point for the team the next time the
entire team was seen in action was when
Thanos showed up and the results were
anything but pretty infinity war began
with the mad Titan and his minions
embarking on their quest for the
Infinity stones in earnest and for much
of the movie The Avengers were scattered
across the galaxy all fighting to the
best of their ability on their own while
several team members were able to
provide a united front to makanda an
Iron Man and spider-man were able to
team up with Doctor Strange and the
guardians of the galaxy on Titan Thanos
ended up having relatively minimal
trouble getting through each of the
groups separately as the infinity war
credits rolled Tony Stark was stranded
on the other side of the solar system
with the remaining Avengers wallowing in
the dust back on earth the questions
that remain going forward are if how and
when the team will finally reassemble
for the first time since the end of
phase 2 to take on Thanos with a final
united front in an interview with Empire
magazine
Marvel boss Kevin Feige explained just
how important endgame is as a capstone
for the entire first three phases of the
MCU he explained we wanted to bring to a
conclusion a series of movies in a way
that had never been done before Harry
Potter had an ending because there were
only so many books Lord of the Rings -
but we thought 22 movies in wouldn't it
be fun to bring some finality to the
storyline the knowledge that the
creator's themselves see and
a sort of capstone for the first three
phases of Marvel movies is reason enough
to expect that the Avengers particularly
the central six that have been so
focused on so far will play critical
roles the fact that they were all left
standing along with the heavy focus on
them in the promotional material for
endgame seems to imply that the Infinity
Saga that started with the founding of
Avengers will end with them as well
while the Infinity saga may be drawing
to a close the sky's the limit for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as the studio
moves forward from endgame at this point
a whole new batch of potential Avenger
material is available in the form of
newer characters like Spider Man
black panther and the newest member of
the mall Captain Marvel in addition
there's the boatload of a list Marvel
characters brought into the fold thanks
to the Disney Fox merger
the point is Marvel has a lot to work
with and the abundance of options opens
up the possibility for endgame to be
more than a long-awaited reunion of old
friends saving the world yet again while
it's sad to think of going into phase 4
without all of the original Avengers
around there's no doubt that their
influence will continue to be felt for
years to come check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about Avengers endgame are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]